the Biden Administration clearly isn't
worried at all about the crisis at the
southern border I don't think they're
paying attention to it at all this is
proof by the fact that Joe Biden is now
heading to Saint Croix in the U.S Virgin
Islands for some sun rest and relaxation
meanwhile gangs and human traffickers
not only have free run of the Border
they basically control it as they're
profiting heavily fueling their criminal
Enterprise
but they're not only taking over the
Texas border Arizona is also in this
crisis in crosshairs this month alone
Customs officials at a single port of
entry in the state of Arizona in Nogales
seized roughly 2 million fentanyl pills
last month that very same Port of Entry
seized more than 3 million fentanyl
pills and of course that's just what CBP
was able to detect the full extent of
the drug trafficking and human
trafficking that's occurring and the
consequences on our country especially
through our border in Arizona this is
almost impossible to measure
our government both Democrats and
Republicans have clearly failed to
secure our borders either because they
just don't care about the American
people our security or our country or
they're totally incompetent Mexico
certainly not doing anything to secure
its own borders and keep people from
entering our country they're essentially
a narco state that is controlled by and
facilitating these cartels who are the
ones who are winning in all of this
and so the result is that like Texas
Arizona is also experiencing an
unprecedented wave of illegal migration
but keep in mind the impact doesn't stop
there it doesn't stop at our border
states because they're just way stations
for this surge of illegal migration that
frankly is impacting every state across
the country
now the daily callers Jorge Ventura was
at the Yuma Border in the middle of the
night just before Christmas
here's some disturbing footage of what
he saw
we are approaching four in the morning
here in Yuma Arizona this is the
currency we're seeing a massive line
here of migrants from all over the world
from Russia Peru Brazil Colombia Cuba
this is one of the more sophisticated
human smoking operations this once again
shows we're taking here to this massive
line here this is once again shows the
amount of control the Mexican drug
cartels have on this border secretary
marioquez continues to say that the
borders coaches massive line shows
different
Ali Bradley of news Nation reported
today that she saw more than 400
migrants cross into Yuma this morning
alone now many of them she said are from
Moldova Russia and Cuba and according to
Bradley quote one moldovan man told us
he took an Uber from Tijuana to this
drop-off point and he says he was told
the border is open
now as Jorge Ventura found human
Smugglers have received that message
loud and clear Ventura confirmed that
many young people are being brought to
the Border by human Smugglers
so that we actually have the human
Smuggler he's uh trying to flash this
light to my camera and block us from
filming him he was actually calling me
out yesterday for uh filming him here
yesterday and he's bringing another big
group here
that's why he's using that strobe to
block me from getting his face this time
as he's actually taking money payments
right now
officials in Arizona say they're not
getting any help from the federal
government in deterring this illegal
migration and human trafficking in fact
the Biden Administration has
successfully pressured Arizona to stop
using shipping containers that they put
up as makeshift barriers to keep illegal
migrants out
now governor-elect Katie Hobbs has also
vowed to stop using these containers as
blockades in just a moment we're going
to speak to Mark Daniels the sheriff of
Cochise County about the fight over
those very shipping containers but first
we're going to go to the Daily callers
Jorge Ventura who shot the footage from
Arizona that we just showed you uh Jorge
you are exposing the lie that the Biden
Administration is telling us about how
the borders are secure and closed tell
us what's happening on the ground right
now
yeah and Yuma Arizona is one of the more
sophisticated human operations that I've
reported I've been reporting in South
Texas California and Arizona but in Yuma
what makes it particularly interesting
is around two in the morning on the
Mexican side you'll see a massive wave
of vehicle traffic after the migrants
are dropped off you'll see four or five
human smokers guide these migrants we're
talking about hundreds of migrants from
all over the world so I got to meet
migrants from Russia Afghanistan Bolivia
Peru Brazil Cuba there's there's been
smuggled in the middle of the night
hundreds overwhelming border patrol
officials and luckily we were able to
track down one of those human smoking
routes get the Smugglers on camera what
makes this actually more interesting
Tulsi is how brazing these mothers are
walking on American soil and taking
payments as they continue to smuggle
hundreds and after a week caught The
Smuggler on camera he couldn't care less
he just returned to the Mexican side and
continued bringing groups and it just
overwhelms border patrol officials on
the on the Yuma side there was actually
one point where it was around six in the
morning I was staring at a group of 300
migrants with no border patrol agents to
apprehend them or process them because
they have to attend to other other areas
and it's just been a complete mess in
disaster and right now the Mexican
cartels have full control of the U.S
border I know secretary mayorkas like to
say the board is secured it is
absolutely not it's a different story on
the ground
uh hurry thanks so much for for showing
people exactly what's really happening
at the border because if you watch the
mainstream media you listen to the Biden
Administration in mayorkas they are
blatantly lying to us and what you've
just shown us again is who is actually
in control at the border it's those who
are profiting the most these these
cartels and human traffickers thank you
so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight